[Music]
what FBI informant says that Russia
spent millions of dollars attempting to
influence the Clintons Douglas Campbell
has been supplying the FBI with
information since 2009 he says there was
an extensive kickback and bribery scheme
and to secure approval of that famous
uranium deal now a testimony to three
separate congressional committees
Campbell says Russia the government
spent millions through the lobbying firm
APCO Worldwide in Washington to assist
the global Clinton initiative they did
this in the hope that the Obama
administration would then treat Russia
favorably on the deal
Peter Schweitzer is the author of
Clinton cash news called things are just
for many years and he joins us tonight
so Peter how I mean this seems like a
big story doesn't mean it will be
covered by anybody but us tomorrow but
this man at the center of it Campbell
can you explain his role in this sure so
camels a very interesting guy he has a
history that that hints at some
background either in the military or
intelligence but he found himself in the
mid-2000s at basically serving in this
capacity with tedx this Russian firm as
a consultant they were paying him
$50,000 a month to help things happen in
Washington DC as a consultant he saw
what was happening he became an
informant for the FBI and started
sharing information and what he is
saying is that you know in this
2009-2010 period when uranium one was
being considered and finally approved by
the Obama administration that the
Russians were funneling money through
aapko this lobbying firm in an effort to
help that happen and to benefit Hillary
Clinton and he says he told the FBI
about this back in 2010 and they
basically tried to bury it ever since
interesting what's so striking about the
stories the Russians were concerned that
this deal wouldn't go through and yet
we've been assured by everyone in
Washington the establishment many idiot
news anchors in the tank for the left
but all sort of response people oh is no
big deal it was authorized by all these
different agencies it was not
controversial
but it was controversial there were
people who thought it was a bad idea to
give any of our uranium to a Russian
company weren't there oh that that's
exactly right I mean you know take
congressman King from Long Island he was
the ranking member on the Homeland
Security Committee he's not a bomb
thrower by any means he was a nose to
this deal the the ranking Republican on
the House Foreign Affairs Committee was
opposed to this deal senator Barroso of
Wyoming was opposed to this deal all
raising legitimate questions and
concerns about it so this was a
controversial deal outside the Obama
administration but within the Obama
administration that was very little
debate and it was rammed through rather
quickly so we at this point are we
certain and I don't wanna get over the
are skis at all on this but are we
certain that the government of russia
spent money in order to lobby the obama
administration perhaps the Clintons she
was serving in Secretary of State at the
time in order to secure this uranium
deal we know that well what we know is
that the that the Russians gave money to
AB Co three million dollars the Russians
according to Campbell in audio and
videotapes that the FBI have say that it
was used for the purposes of uranium one
aapko is denying that and say no it
involved other work that they were doing
on behalf of Russia and of course that's
part of the problem Tucker is all this
Russian money is sloshing around
Washington DC and and so it's not a
surprise that there are a lot of people
that are making money and a lot of
people that were trying to do bidding
for Moscow whether it was on uranium one
or on other issues and if you're gonna
pretend that Russia is our greatest
international threat you'd have to be
concerned about this but of course
they're not because they're liars Peter
thank you good to see you thanks doctor